Speaker 1: Let's take a few more calls via The
David Pakman Show Discord, you can find it at
David Pakman dot com slash discord slash discord
is the place. Let's go to Harper from Europe.
Europe is such a vague location, Harper.
Speaker 3: Oh, yeah. I'm actually
in France right now. Oh, all
Speaker 1: right. Love France.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah. I've been here for about a
month. Anyway, regarding the Calvert Nostril. No,
I'm kidding. I just want to say, since I've
been here for over a month and you were in
Spain in August, I wanted to touch on the whole
anti-vaccine, sure anti-vax scene. Yes. Yeah. So
I've heard very often about American politics that
we're sort of like kind of a crap show and people
look from other countries in on the United States
and like, what the heck is going on? But I want
to say this sort of an exception to be made and
not sure if you agree with the anti-vax situation
here. While I'm in France, it seems like since
I left the United States, I'm from California.
Things are just as bad as here. And yes, in fact,
Speaker 1: we've talked about it in France. I
don't want to cut you off, but just so I did
remind my audience. Go ahead. I have mentioned
in France they are having a serious anti-vax
issue Italy as well, by the way. But in France,
I think the government did something astute,
which is instead of doing a straight correct
me if I'm wrong, instead of doing a straight up
vaccine requirement, they've just said, if you
want to go here, here, there, there, there, you
need proof of vaccination. You don't have to go
and get a vaccine. But if you want to hang out in
these cafes or movie theaters or whatever the case
may be. And it is. It is made. As I understand it,
a lot more people sort of say, Well, I really want
to do that, so I'm going to go and get a vaccine.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that that's that's absolutely
true. And then there's a small aspect of this
that I don't quite see in the United States
that, I would argue makes it slightly worse over
here. OK. And that is that the if you split the
the groups, people who are vaccinated people or
not, there's more animosity over here between
those two groups than there is in the United
States really seems a bit more tame where I came
from. Yeah. And then I was in Catalonia and seemed
about the same over there. And I was wondering,
since you were in Spain, which is part of
Catalonia, about half or maybe two thirds was
Spain, like in sort of the realm of of countries
that have an anti-vax situation? Or was it like
not at all? No. In fact, pretty much. At the time
Speaker 1: that I was in Spain, Spain was only
about 45 percent vaccinated. But when European
countries were polled, do you want the vaccine?
Spain was off the charts. It was something
like 88 or 91 percent of Spaniards were
saying I plan to get vaccinated, which
was one of the highest in all of Europe.
Speaker 3: Interesting. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Martin, thank you. All right,
thank you. Appreciate that great. Great call from
France there. France. Let's go next. Why don't
we try? Chris from Colorado? Chris,
you're on the air. Chris from Colorado.
Don't be our first dropped call, we want
you to unmute so that I can hear you.
Speaker 3: Oh, no.
Speaker 1: Chris,
from Colorado, last chance, my friend. And
that is too bad, I thought maybe we would get
through the entire day without a drop,
but we didn't do it, we didn't do it.